avant que cette vidéo commence on a eu
le temps au dernier moment avec trafic
de sortir cette nouvelle collection on
ressort le que hésiter qu'on avait sorti
il ya plusieurs mois que vous aviez qui
fait on ressort la summer edition genre
c'est juste un t-shirt donc a pas de
souhaits de cette fois juste un t-shirt
blanc pour l'été quoi
voilà donc les prêts qu elles ont
commencé aujourd'hui c'est pendant 31
jours donc au 1er juillet
bah on va commencer à envoyer pour tous
ceux qui ont commandé j'ai dit n'importe
quoi
en fait ces 30 jours et donc ça sera au
3 juillet que ce sera la fin des prix qu
est que du combat commence à envoyer
voilà désolé donc donc logo brodé un
comme d'hab tee shirt 100 % coton et où
vous le connaissez ce qu'ils ont ce
qu'ils ont acheté savent à quel point
c'est cali voilà je vous refais pas le
topo
il est voilà c'est la même gamme que
d'habitude c'est la qualité
merci d'ailleurs pour tous vos retours
sur le souhaitent bada socrates et le
t-shirt bada socrates
h vous recevez les produits vous êtes
satisfait et ça bah ça me fait plaisir
donc voilà deux pour interrogation qui
forme un coeur parce que on aime la
curiosité on aime se poser des questions
disponible pendant 30 jours pour cet été
vous malien dans la description et je
vous laisse avec la vidéo
bon visionnage juste avant je monte vite
et est ce que ça fait de vous pour info
ça c'était du xs maintenant je mets du s
violée par abbott j'espère que vous
allez bien bienvenue dans ce nouvel
épisode de ed wood et merde
le concept c'est quoi sa télé très sain
vous m'envoyer une histoire un truc qui
vous arrive une décision en fait que
vous avez prises par truc qui nous
arrive dans ce qui nous est arrivé
c'est important que ce soit du passé
parce que si c'est du présent jeu jeu
c'est notre posture ok moi je suis là
pour vous juger hawks est totalement
anonymisée vous l'envoyez depuis une
adresse mail qui est anonymisé via un
service que je vous mets en descriptions
et apparemment ça a été vachement
respecter donc merci beaucoup moi cette
boîte mail c'est mon monteur alfie qui
la tchèque et qui m'envoient des petites
pépites qu'il a sélectionnées et ensuite
je fais du mieux possible pour vous
juger de manière qualitative et
déterminer si oui ou non vous êtes une
merde
du coup c'est parti quoi les phoques
ingo est ce que vous êtes des mets
[Musique]
suis-je une merde pour avoir abandonné
ma grande soeur en fauteuil roulant dans
la rue ah ça commence fort en gros
j'avais 15 ans elle a eu un accident de
moto en sortant de l'hôpital elle est
venue vivre avec ma mère ma troisième
grande soeur et moi du coup tout le
monde à la maison est aux petits soins
avec elle à cette époque a été
désagréable avec tout le monde en
particulier avec moi la plus jeune de la
famille c'était une boule de nerfs et en
tant qu'adolescente j'étais pas mieux
autant vous dire qu'on l'a confié jamais
un jour ma mère ayant un rendez-vous me
dépose ma soeur en fauteuil et me
demandent de l'emmener faire des petites
courses en sortant des cours quatre
heures de sport ce jour là par la
précision
elle s'en souvient et s'en souvient
c'était les quatre heures de sport avait
l'air douloureuse j'accepte quand bien
même j'étais fatigué attendait pas
vraiment le choix j'ai l'impression à au
magasin avec ma soeur me demande de la
pousser dans tous les rayons pour faire
du lèche vitrine
j'accepte à contrecoeur en des autres ça
lui ferait du bien psychologiquement
j'aurais pas dû grosse erreur de ma part
vraiment là pour l'instant dans
l'histoire on comprend pas en quoi c'est
une erreur juste deux bains juste de dd
tu as heures à regarder ce qu'il ya dans
les vitrines quoi tu vois ma soeur peser
de base 85 kg + 20 25 kg de petites
courses sans compter mon sac de cours je
galère a poussé fauteuil je ne sais pas
où on va avec cette histoire je sais pas
où on va
à mi chemin de la maison elle se tourne
vers moi et me hurle dessus tu ne va pas
assez vite
t'es qu'une merde va plus vite que sa
[ __ ] limite alors eu un fouet et
j'aurais été devant le fauteuil avec un
ara mais elle pourrait fouetter le cul
les gens autour me regarder comme si
j'étais un monstre parce qu'une personne
handicapée me crie dessus j'ai pété mon
câble et jeudi mot pour mot va te faire
[ __ ] des mers toi tout seul moi je me
casse j'ai pris les courses parce que je
ne suis pas inhumaines mon fils de [ __ ]
attends je l'aimé j'en ai mis un peu
près je l'enlève un peu je voulais qu'il
a sur jolicloud sur ton t-shirt le
crachat en fait je voulais pas qu'ils
aillent sur ton visage suis désolé
attend excuse moi voilà désolé désolé
mais tu es merde quand même et je suis
rentré chez moi sans me retourner elle a
galéré à rentrer pas d'accès handicapés
valable
résidence et ne m'a plus jamais demandé
de la pousse en fauteuil fait chier de
te dire ça met un peu une merde pour moi
le fait de partir et de la laisser en
plan tu brises une sorte de contrat
social tu vois là il ya un espace
relationnel un espace relationnel quand
et avec l aide de gueule dessus et tu
peux lui gueuler dessus en retour tu vas
vous pouvez vous disputez etc
mais le fait de partir tu brises cet
espace relationnel d'une certaine
manière vous ayez un espace assez serein
dans la relation pour vous puissiez vous
embrouiller
en fait vous mettre sur la gueule toi et
tu puisses que répondre alors ouais tu
me parle pas comme ça en fait surtout un
public
je fais ce que je peux ces lourds etc je
fais ce que je peux
ok j'ai fait du sport machin je fais ce
que je peux mais ce bar et s'est brisé
cet espace je trouve et vu que c'est toi
qui brisent l'espace pour moi c'est toi
qu'il merde là mais whaou
en tout cas j'espère que maintenant tout
roule entre vous suis-je une merde pour
avoir simulé avec tous mes partenaires
alalala la classique lac le clasico
comme on dit je précise que je suis une
femme je pense que cette information est
importante pour comprendre le problème
dans ce cas beaucoup d'hommes qui simule
je sais pas c'est une bonne question
c'est un homme et que vous simulez
faites-nous part de votre expérience en
commentaire un jour j'ai fait ma
première fois je n'ai pas eu d'orgasme
après ce jour et dans toutes mes
relations qui ont suivi je n'ai pas eu
le regard déjà de la part de tous les
hommes désolé votre orgasme est aussi
important que l'orgasme notre partenaire
le rapport sexuel ne s'arrête pas quand
vous ai-je acculé les hommes et ne
commence pas quand vous avez une
érection aller au delà la pénétration il
faut changer son mindset sur internet on
trouve des articles expliquant qu'un
certain pourcentage de femmes sont
incapables d'avoir des orgasmes j'étais
donc persuadé que c'était mon cas et
m'étais résigné à simuler le restant de
mes jours en ces durs pourquoi simulé
pour ne pas vexer mes partenaires et
surtout à cause de la pression sociale
qui assure la femme frigide amf rigide
c'est cette femme qui au lit c'est la
fameuse étoile de mer quelque part
inerte pendant six ans j'ai eu de
nombreux partenaires des relations
longues des coups d'un soir est le
problème ne venait donc pas des
partenaires mais bien de moi
c'est pas vrai à un jour un homme a fait
jouir au là là mais quel champion quel
master class puis ce jour je n'ai plus
aucun souci pour la bagasse
là le mec c'est la clé c'est la clé on
veut le contact de se mettre maintenant
que je sais que je ne suis pas frigide
je me demande beaucoup c'est en
discutant de cela avec mes partenaires
le problème aurait-il pu se régler
beaucoup plus tôt c'est sûr c'est sur le
sexe et que la communication mais la
question qui se pose c'est surtout
suis-je une merde pouvoir simuler un
orgasme dans toutes mes relations
sexuelles et donc avoir menti à tous mes
partenaires je pense que pas de la seule
dans mon cas il ya un tel tabou sur
l'orgasme féminin
je voulais aussi servir de témoignage
alors merci merci pour ce témoignage ça
dépend de pourquoi tu mens toi et là tu
mens pour voilà pour préserver les go je
pense de ton partenaire n'est pas une
merde pour ça c'est mieux
effectivement de communiqué c'est mieux
de dire les choses tu vois je pense
qu'en fait en fait ce truc de être une
merde il ya aussi où en est la société
et tu vois et comment tu te positionnes
par rapport à cette société on est
tellement en retard sur l'orgasme
féminin est tellement de gars les mêmes
de meuf d'ailleurs qui ont cette vision
encore du sexe a marqué par l'orgasme
masculin en fait que je pourrais pas
qualifier quelqu'un qui est dans cette
vision d'être merde pour moi une merde
ce serait ok on a tous compris la
personne le sait elle ne fait aucun
effort
c'est une merde je pense pas que ce soit
le cas là pour eux et pour toi en grand
- toi t'as juste essayé de bien faire
est a juste voulu bien faire pas de
honte tu vois tu dis personne dans mon
entourage
même mes amis les plus proches n'étaient
au courant j'avais extrêmement honte
honte de quoi tu vois les gars ils n'ont
pas réussi
c'était trop mal à l'aise de leur
renvoyer le fait qu'ils aient pas réussi
donc tu t'es mis en porte-à-faux pour
les protéger d'une certaine manière tu
n'as pas avoir honte de ça merci
beaucoup pour ton témoignage en tout cas
c'est hyper intéressant on t'embrasse et
on espère que le mec qui a réussi à te
donner un orgasme et qui a créé ce
déclic va faire un bouquin ou une master
class une formation en ligne
suis-je une merde pour ne pas avoir
souscrit un abonnement à cette splendide
séduction
ce oui qu'est-ce que je te dise oui je
rigole je fais ce que tu veux moi je
t'aime quoi qu'il arrive même si t'es
pas abonné je prends pas liste suis-je
une merde pour ne pas être affecté par
la mort de ma copine wright âgées
étaient en couple
ah ouais c'est ta meuf un jeu acceptant
sa copine genre une pote
ok j'ai été en couple pendant huit ans
et on a commencé à sortir ensemble vers
17 ans et ça allait bien au début en
fait au fur et à mesure j'ai moins aimé
ma copine jusqu'au point de ne plus être
amoureux sauf que cela faisait bien six
mois un an que je n'arrivais pas à
rentrer impossible pour moi et un jour
ma copine est morte cancer du cerveau et
en un mois c'était fini en gros c'est
pas dans aujourd'hui je vois sa mère
dévastée et je vois mon entourage en
pâtir mais moi je suis soulagé ou
soulagé de ne pas avoir à rompre avec
elle je suis pas content faut pas
déconner mais juste une partie de moi
est soulagé de ce fils d'une mère de
ressentir une certaine forme de
soulagement
tu seras jamais une merde pour ressentir
quelque chose sûre je te dirai jamais tu
es une merde parce que tu ressens ça
c'est parce que je veux dire donc non en
fait c'est la question c'est est ce que
tu es une merde pour ressentir ça non ce
n'est pas une merde pour ressentir ça je
comprends que tu culpabilises de
ressentir ça c'est dommage de ressentir
ça intense et ça n'a pas de sens de
juger un ressenti
en fait c'est ça que je comprends pas
dans pourquoi tu enfin ce soulagement en
fait c'est comme si tu te disais c'est
grâce au fait qu'elle soit morte
on n'est plus ensemble il y avait aucune
éventualité pour toi qui à un moment où
tu aurais pu avoir le courage de rompre
c'est ça qui me dérange dans ce
soulagement tu penses vraiment que tu
aurais jamais le courage de rompre
je pense pas j'en suis à un moment tu
aurais eu le courage et donc si tu
acceptes ça le fait qu' il ya un monde
entre elles encourageront ya pas être
soulagé duplication north tu vois je
peux pas dire que tu es une merde pour
un ressenti
ouais t'es de mer pour une action des
maires pour avoir fait mal aux gens d
une merde
[Musique]
comme mal géré une interaction quelque
chose comme ça tu vois et pour ce que tu
ressens je suis qui pour juger ce que tu
ressens après je pense qu'il ya aussi un
truc qui se fait je sais pas si vous ça
vous arrive parfois je prends la place
qui est vide entre guillemets que si je
vois tout le monde extrêmement triste
pour quelque chose
ben j'sais pas réussir à être triste il
ya trop de tristesse autour de moi que
tu vois et je n'arrive pas à rejoindre
le truc toi et quand on est des fois on
est hyper triste pour moi on est
tellement triste pour moi que ma moi du
coup j'arrive pas à triste genre c'est
trop ça me vois c'est peut-être ça qui
ressemble n'était que du coup il ya des
choses mélanger et donc tu mets
soulagement et humer l'étiquette
soulagement surtout ça et peut-être qui
voit là il ya c'est une chose de ne pas
être foncièrement genre hyper triste et
c'est une chose d'être soulagé et tu
vois et peut-être que tu as une
personnalité qui fait que voilà tu veux
tu étais triste moins longtemps que
plein de gens de morale à cette histoire
la première c'est que quand vous n'êtes
quand vous voulez plus être avec
quelqu'un vous êtes sûr que vous ne
voulez plus partagé la vie de cette
personne est bien
rompez et 2e moral si vous aimez
quelqu'un et que vous êtes avec profit
des enfants quoi parce que ça peut
s'arrêter très vite suis une merde pour
être sorti avec quelqu'un par profite à
la la la la la la
bonjour bonjour l'ordre on arrive au
lycée je ne connaissais personne dans ma
classe une fille avec qui j'ai constat
parle on a sympathisé pendant quelques
mois je savais qu'elle avait des
sentiments mais moins non elle était
gentil mais physiquement elles me
plaisait pas et son tempérament non plus
pour sortir avec hockey très clair juste
mon prof principal m'a menacé de me
faire redoubler car j'étais mauvais dans
sa matière alors que j'étais très bon
dans les autres j'ai profité des
sentiments de cette fille pour qu'elle
m'aide ème phase des travaux grâce à
elle je suis passé entre temps je me
suis mis avec elle pas par amour mais
pour pouvoir continuer car je savais
qu'elle était crédules et concentre avec
elle elle me refuserai oh là là mais je
souhaite lui avait expliqué la situation
et aurait aidé quand même une fois la
guerre terminée je n'ai pas rempli avec
elle car un drame avait lieu dans sa
famille je me suis dit que je pouvais
pas en plus lui faire ça sachant que
j'étais sa première fois et son premier
amour or la série ben ce qui se passe
mais à la fois veux qu'elle me plaisait
pas physiquement je l'ait trompée six
personnes différentes sur deux ans
je pas lui faire du mal mais un peu
quand même une nouvelle année scolaire
recommence il ya une matière où je suis
mauvais et les tpe aussi dit que
j'allais faire comme l'année dernière oh
là là mais non mais c'est qui cette
personne on a eu en fin d'année
j'obtiens 19 ans tpe et la moyenne dans
la matière que je n'avais pas je suis
content j'ai pas de points à rattraper
bah bravo du coupon félicitations du
coup le jour de la dernière épreuve au
lieu de l'attendre quelques minots si je
suis parti avec quelques amis boire une
bière dans un parc se soucie d'elle et
ignorant ces appels chose qu'elle avait
l'habitude car je l'assommé parfois des
jours entiers et elle accepte et
tellement elle est amoureuse
non mais j'ai pas besoin de terminer
l'histoire lendemain je l'appelle je lui
dis qu'on doit se voir jouer annonce que
ses finitions et donne raison mais je
savais au fond de moi que c'était parce
que pour le reste de mes études m était
inutile
à peine deux mois après je me suis remis
en couple plus ou moins devant elle je
sais que j'ai pas été sympa mais
n'arriveront s'est passé c'est pas ça
pas sympa pas sympa c'est vous vous
dites bon ce soir tu m'as temps pour
garder game of thrones et tu regardes
guimauve tombe sans elle ça c'est pas
sympa mais certains amis et certaines
amis me disent que ça va
j'étais jeune et que en plus je vais
apporter des cadeaux et un soutien
psychologique lors de son problème
familial
ça dépend des cadeaux si c'est une
voiture pourquoi pas fait pousser une
bad c'est une vanne je rigole je suis à
la fois d'accord avec eux mais également
pas en fait je sais pas moi même
maintenant je t'en prie abuse toi sujets
de merde
oh ça me fait de la peine ça me fait de
la peine pour elle et pour toi parce que
parce que j'ai pas que tu culpabilises
si tu veux mais en vrai ouidah et est
une merde en fait surtout surtout que je
pense que vraiment si tu l'avais
expliqué le truc ça aurait pu devenir
une pote et elle aurait pu t'aider toi
va obliger de teint figé ça et lui
infliger ça même d'infliger sa à toi
quoi tu vois genre être avec quelqu'un
avec qui tu es pas amoureux et tout
avoir tout le temps c'est hyper relou
quoi donc je pense que cette décision
est là pas fait souffrir
quelle chance même toit ça doit être
chiant non je sais pas je me mets à
tapas de seconde
votre chien de toute façon moi moi je
suis de l'équipe vérité je trouve que la
vie est tellement plus simple quand on
dit la vérité tellement plus simple je
sais pas pourquoi les gens n'osent pas
dire la vérité dit la vérité dit le ca
vous faire du bien
bon j'espère qu'elle va bien maintenant
cette dame suis-je une merde pour voir
laisser mon directeur se mettre du sur
le visage tous les matins au la hausse à
l'aiea horrible âge le sang vous sentez
ce que ça va être cette histoire là là
là là
ah là là [ __ ] un peu de contexte
c'était il ya quelques années j'étais
animateur sur une colonie de vacances
avec des adolescents ans un camping en
bord de mer ça commence extrêmement mal
le directeur du séjour était très absent
et incompétents spoiler c'est pas une
raison pour les fous du sur le visage
j'étais l'adjoint mais je faisais la
quasi totalité de son travail par
exemple ils prenaient parfois d après
midi entière a couché avec sa copine qui
était en vacances sur le séjour est ce
que par contre elle du coup elle avait
lui aussi sur visage du coup c'est une
revanche
un jour quatre jeunes viennent nous voir
mois et deux autres animateurs pour nous
dire qu'ils ont fait une bêtise c'était
quatre jeunes de 17 ans super sympa
assez mature et responsable preuve en
est que l'été suivant et en passer leur
bafa
je les ai recrutés dans l'équipe d'un
nouveau séjour ils ont été des éléments
moteurs oreilles tu pourrais tu nous
vends les quatre jeunes et quel jeune de
17 ans coule guys
ok cette bêtise était d'avoir tous les
quatre dans le pot de crème de visage du
directeur qu'ils avaient ensuite
mélangés et reposer dans son bungalow
grosse pack bêtise mur au mur ou là mais
c'est quoi un [ __ ] c'est une bêtise
mais gros c'est quand même une bêtise
très haut niveau ça non mais attends et
ensuite à rien dit au directeur
tout ceci la veille le mal était déjà
fait le directeur s'était déjà est allée
du surtout visage le matin même c'est
infernal
après avoir réfléchi et que les autres
animateurs nous avons décidé de ne rien
dire car mise à part cette bêtise les
quatre jeunes étaient vraiment très bien
il avait pris l'initiative de nous dire
la vérité mais comme des mises à part
ces bêtises a mis à part le fait d'avoir
un pouls et d'avoir mélangé pour le
guest le maître dessus c'est vraiment
des gars bien non non on fait pas ça on
ne fait pas ça nous ne voulions pas
qu'il se fasse renvoyé de plus le
directeur ne se rendaient pas contre il
se sent sûrement bien plus heureux de ne
pas savoir qui s'est étalée du visage
tous les matins alors si j'ai une mère
d'avoir laissé mon directeur de séjour
s'étaler du visage tous les matins à
pour moi oui ton job c'est de surveiller
cueillez pas de connerie et qui ont des
conneries et quand il ya des conneries
et recadrer xetra et voilà le gars il a
fait une fois il se l'est me suis-je
bon c'est une fois tant pis mais là le
fait de pas lui dire il le fait tous les
matins gros ça soit 800 il encore faire
le fer là c'est ce coup là il a racheté
la même crème esi s'échoue elle n'a pas
la même texture quand même à temps mais
le gage or le matin il s'en est pas
rendu compte
il a changé depuis sidi mon mac rae
maile et à la des grumeaux maintenant
oui mais merde
après voilà ça tue pas voilà c'est
peut-être même bon pour la peau s'est
pas tu vois d'ailleurs ce serait
intéressant à étudier quoi si tu as
était encore en contact et le directeur
ausculte sa peau regarde comment ça se
passe peut-être qu'on est sur quelque
chose j'espère que cet épisode vous aura
plu il ya eu des choses un petit peu
plus corsée si je vous ai dit que vous
étiez une merde je ne voulais pas mal
pris vous avez bien compris que c'était
un événement précis que ça pas de vous
une merde dans votre globalité
al'inverse si j'ai dit que vous étiez
pas une merde sur un événement précis ça
se trouve vous êtes une mère dans la
globalité en ce cas je fais hyper
content que ce format vous plaisent moi
c'est un kiff a tourné le mardi à 22h
je suis sur twitter n'hésitez pas à me
suivre twitch point tv slash cyrus north
gemmois sur instagram aussi instagram
points comme slash cyrus north
voilà voilà voilà prenez soin de vous
faites les bonnes décisions dit la
vérité aux gens simplement hou là soyez
honnêtes soyez honnêtes soyez vrai fait
du mieux que vous pouvez love peace ciao
[Musique]